Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work is about improving reinforcement
learning.
Reinforcement learning is a learning algorithm
that we can use to choose a set of actions
in an environment to maximize a score.
Our classical example applications are helicopter
control, where the score to be maximized would
be proportional to the distance that we traveled
safely, or any computer game of your choice
where a score can describe how well we are
doing.
For instance, in Frostbite, our score describes
how many jumps we have survived without dying
and this score is subject to maximization.
Earlier, scientists at DeepMind combined a
reinforcement learner with a deep neural network
so the algorithm could look at the screen
and play the game much like a human player
would.
This problem is especially difficult when
the rewards are sparse.
This is similar to what a confused student
would experience after a written exam when
only one grade is given, but the results for
the individual problems are not shown.
It is quite hard to know where we did well
and where we missed the mark, and it is much
more challenging to choose the appropriate
topics to study to do better next time.
When starting out, the learner starts exploring
the parameter space and performs crazy, seemingly
nonsensical actions until it finds a few scenarios
where it is able to do well.
This can be thought of as adding noise to
the actions of the agent.
Scientists at OpenAI proposed an approach
where they add noise not directly to the actions,
but the parameters of the agent, which results
in perturbations that depend on the information
that the agent senses.
This leads to less flailing and a more systematic
exploration that substantially decreases the
time taken to learn tasks with sparse rewards.
For instance, it makes a profound difference
if we use it in the walker game.
As you can see here, the algorithm with the
parameter space noise is able to learn the
concept of galloping, while the traditional
method does, well, I am not sure what it is
doing to be honest, but it is significantly
less efficient.
The solution does not come without challenges.
For instance, different layers respond differently
to this added noise, and, the effect of the
noise on the outputs grows over time, which
requires changing the amount of noise to be
added depending on its expected effect on
the output.
This technique is called adaptive noise scaling.
There are plenty of comparisons and other
cool details in the paper, make sure to have
a look, it is available in the video description.
DeepMind's deep reinforcement learning was
published in 2015 with some breathtaking results
and superhuman plays on a number of different
games, and it has already been improved leaps
and bounds beyond its initial version.
And we are talking about OpenAI, so of course,
the source code of this project is available
under the permissive MIT license.
In the meantime, we have recently been able
to upgrade the entirety of our sound recording
pipeline through your support on Patreon.
I have been yearning for this for a long-long
time now and not only that, but we could also
extend our software pipeline with sound processing
units that use AI and work like magic.
Quite fitting for the series, right?
Next up is a recording room or recording corner
with acoustic treatment, depending on our
budget.
Again, thank you for your support, it makes
a huge difference.
A more detailed write-up on this is available
in the video description, have a look.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!